what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and the fantastic four
are making their way to the mcu not too
long from now we do have a couple of
years to wait but of course as we in the
fandom know the hype for movie starts
way before the release of an actual
movie in fact for both the fantastic
four and the x-men the hype for both of
these films to finally make their way to
the mcu has been going on for years now
ever since the disney fox deal but now
we are closer with an actual release
date and we might actually have our
casting for mr fantastic we also have a
list of names of who could be cast as
sue storm now it does seem like marvel
studios is kind of getting things
together officially for the fantastic
four at this point in time we know that
marvel studios president kevin feige is
really really trying to make sure that
the fantastic four is sort of the
perfect movie this is his baby this is
marvel's first family and kevin feige
has expressed many times how important
this movie is to him so it would make
sense that they would start preparing
for this movie and start getting the
perfect cast together way in advance and
we could have our mr fantastic right now
in the mcu and it looks like the casting
for sue storm is not far away at all so
let's start off by talking about mr
fantastic now right away a lot of talk
has been going around this morning about
the fantastic four in general and many
insiders and some influencers have been
speaking out about what they have heard
now the first name that has been tossed
out for mr fantastic is pen badgely
according to the marvel vision podcast
they have heard that pin badgeley has
reportedly been contacted to play reed
richards in the fantastic four or i
should clarify and say that he's been
contacted about playing reed richards of
the fantastic four in the mcu now if you
don't know who penn badgley is he is
quite famous and he has been in a lot of
really great things he was in john
tucker must die he was an easy a he
played a big role in gossip girl and
many people probably know him from the
series u now i've seen his stuff and i
actually think that he would make a good
young reed richards obviously if marvel
studios is contacting penn badgley about
playing reed richards they are looking
for a young reed richards not the older
more sophisticated reed richards that we
all pretty much know but i think pin
would actually be a pretty good choice
and this would stick true to the rumors
that we've been hearing for a while that
marvel studios wants to cast some really
big names but also some lesser-known
names and while i definitely give credit
to penn badgley i do believe there are
quite a few people out there who don't
really know who he is so he could be one
of those lesser known names but when we
get into sue storm you can see that
there are some pretty big names that
marvel studios is looking into casting
but staying on reed richards for just a
bit when all of this casting news
started breaking out this morning an
interesting rumor started going around
from grace randolph now grace randolph
has been right about scoops in the past
which is why i am mentioning it however
you should take this with a grain of
salt but what she said is quite
interesting this morning she tweeted
stating the casting list for reed
richards is so good like you see one
name and you're like wow but then you
see the next and you're like omg what a
sophie's choice for feige the role
hasn't been cast yet but soon might be
one of the best mcu castings ever she
then went on to also say some of the
names have been floating around lately
two i haven't seen anywhere else when
they announced the casting i'll tell you
who almost got it one person is someone
who worked on a huge disney franchise
already and then she tweeted the star
wars logo now when i read this i think
of oscar isaac but of course he cannot
be cast as reed richards because he is
already moon knight so the next choice
for me would have to be ewan mcgregor
and i love ewan i think he's phenomenal
but i see him as obi-wan and he's
recently stated that he's in the star
wars franchise and doesn't really feel
like he needs to move into marvel
however you never really know now the
other two names i could think of are
adam driver and john boyega and quite
honestly i don't really see either of
them being mr fantastic i actually think
that out of anybody in the star wars
franchise i would still rather take pin
badgely but apparently there are some
big names being considered alongside of
pin and it does look like marvel studios
is pretty close at an official casting
which means an official casting
announcement shouldn't be too far away
yes we have d23 coming up in a little
bit over a week and that would be the
perfect opportunity to announce an
official cast for the fantastic four and
who knows maybe they have already picked
the actors they want just nobody knows
that it's official yet but moving on to
sue storm and i really really like these
names now this is coming from an account
great phase who claims to be an insider
they've been right about a few things
but also been wrong so take this with a
grain of salt as well but here are the
names that they've listed lily james
amanda seifried phillip passou jody
comer sercia ronan and vanessa kirby now
honestly this list to me is pretty
fantastic there are some really great
names on here i really think amanda
seyfried would make a great sioux storm
but actually to me it's the last three
names that i think would just be perfect
jodie comer sercia ronan and vanessa
kirby i love all three of these
actresses if you don't know who joanie
comer is if you've seen the movie free
guy you know who she is she plays
molotov girl the main character
alongside of ryan reynolds now if you
don't know who circa ronan is i highly
recommend you watch some of her films
you might know her from the movie hannah
which was a while ago the grand budapest
hotel and recently i think most people
know her from the movie lady bird also
if you're a music fan she was in the ed
sheeran music video galway girl now i
think she would make a slightly better
shoe storm than jody comer however
vanessa kirby kind of ties with sercia
ronan for me or could be slightly better
i'm not really sure i really like
vanessa kirby if you don't know who she
is the most popular movies that she's
been in are the fast and the furious
presents hobbs and shaw she was in
mission impossible fallout and she plays
princess margaret on the crown and i
honestly think this would be a
phenomenal casting choice i would love
vanessa kirby to play sue storm in the
mcu i've been a fan of vanessa kirby for
a bit now i think she's a great actress
and i think she just fits the bill for
sue storm but that's not to discredit
any of the other women on this list i
think really you couldn't go wrong with
any of them and these are big names
especially amanda seyfried that's a
pretty big name and apparently there are
some really big names for reed richards
as well now what's interesting is that
we haven't really heard anything about a
possible casting for the human torch or
ben grimm the thing now admittingly i
think mr fantastic and sue storm the
invisible woman are the most important
casting choices when it comes to the
fantastic four one is well because the
thing he's probably going to be mocap
it's gonna be cgi right so the actor
isn't as important there as far as looks
wise it's more about the personality and
the voice that they want behind it and
johnny storm sue storm's brother of
course is a huge part of the fantastic
four but perhaps they want to cast sue
first and then cast somebody that kind
of looks like her because of course
johnny storm and sue storm are brother
and sister plus not to mention reed
richards and ben graham are best friends
so once you get reed richards you can
find another actor that vibes well with
mr fantastic now i will say i can also
see penn badgley and vanessa kirby
together on screen i can also see penn
badgley pretty much with any of these
women that have been listed but not
gonna lie i still do have a soft spot
for john krasinski i would still like
him to be mr fantastic he is a little
bit older so i get it if marvel studios
is kind of going for a younger fantastic
four he might not fit the casting but he
was phenomenal in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness i mean when i see
him now i simply see reed richards but
hey let me know what you think about all
of these casting choices in the comments
down below do you have a specific person
that you would like to play each role in
the fantastic four if you do let me know
in the comments also please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you